because it opens the pathway towards a
Quantum gravitational understanding of
nature which the community has been
entirely ignoring
[Music]
can you tell us more about the modified
theory of gravity how is it modified and
how does it make the theory different
from how we've understood it it was
already weird bending space time that's
already pretty darn weird from from
Einstein what else do you need to
account for dark matter
well I am the idea with spending
space-time is brilliant and that
formulation is disciple thesis so it's
one way to hopefully understand what
gravitation is but it doesn't mean that
that theory is correct there are other
ideas what gravitation could be and that
is where Linda's concept that
it's gravitation is an emergent Force
because the information content
different regions of space is different
another possibility is that you get
gravitation because particles have wave
nature and gravitation just comes about
because of changes in refractive index
which their parties themselves because
they are oscillating in a
vacuum that Medium coated ether and that
changes refractive index and that
induces gravitational forces so they are
very different in the interpretation of
what gravitation could be we don't know
what is that um gravity waves which
recently have been detected well the
gravitational waves
um collapse the possibilities of how we
understand gravitation so if any
gravitational Theory does not
accommodate gravitational waves or it
doesn't accumulate accommodate them
traveling with a speed of light that
theory is ruled out yeah and this for
example has narrowed
the possibilities in mind so the
original version of a relativistic
formulation of Mont had gravitational
waves
propagating with a different speed and
that has been now of course falsified
but now there are other theories which
accommodate it but that's still
interpreting gravitation as a
geometrical effect which again itself
might not be correct I'm very
pragmatical what I rather rather than
spending much of my time thinking about
what gravitation could be in terms of
its deepest origin
I want to put into the computer a law of
gravitation with which we can study the
law of gravitation by looking at what we
observe out there and I know now and
that is a uh in physics we call that a
five Sigma detection threshold that's
how the Higgs boson was finally accepted
to be uh to be valid to be there is by
reaching the five Sigma detection limit
as the dark matter doesn't exist this
falsifies the validity of einsteinian
gravitation on the scales of gravity of
galaxies and Beyond this means that the
whole model of the universe is probably
not correct and that's where we are at
this very moment to investigate which
new theories could one develop just to
try to help explain how it is ismon
something the first time I came across
the description of it it was something
that seemed to have with have to do with
very distant phenomena in the universe
but in fact I've come to understand that
Monde is very much closer to home if
it's correct yeah right so say something
about it so where does Mont kick in you
would say right so in the solar system
can you encapsulate what Monday if I
understand it's kind of gravity varies
yes okay so tell us a little bit about
mom so
um um as
um Francisco said before Einstein and
gravity has been tested and verified
extremely well in the strong field
regime which means around within the
solar system and stronger fields around
black holes it seems to be working very
well it's an excellent mathematical
description and that uh so any other
Theory would have to accommodate that
but that is always one of the working
principles now now Mont
originally uh um as a description of um
as an acronym for modified internal
Dynamics I prefer to call it milgramian
Dynamics in equivalence to Newtonian
Dynamics so megromian Dynamics comes
about because Milgram noticed where the
measurements of the this galaxies came
in in the early 1980s when for the first
time the velocity field in galaxies were
mapped out to distances of
thousands of light years
that gravity changes and how does it
change well he he noticed that there
seems to be an acceleration scale which
means that in Einstein's view or
description when the when the curvature
of space
becomes very very small that's the
milgram's constant which describes this
curvature a critical curvature beyond
that once we go to nearly flat space
time the um accelerations of objects
appear to be larger
in 1999 Milgram wrote a very interesting
research paper which was more like a
conjecture we suggested that this change
comes about because of the quantum
vacuum the way we under the sustainable
of particle physics is today based on
Quantum field Theory and in there the
ideas the ideas that particles are as
we've heard before excitations in the
fields and there are many fields which
are constantly fluctuating of quantum
mechanical
property of the vacuum and so the vacuum
is constantly has an energy density
which is fluctuating another problem
with that is that the what the energy
density what the astronomers need is 120
orders of magnitude below what the
quantum field theoretists would like the
if I'm if I'm correct then even empty
space is full of energy it's full of
energy and particles pop out of it so
exactly and then disappear exactly
perfectly empty space it's still got
stuff and this is what's modifying and
gravity in this well exactly so the idea
of Milgram was that when you move
through this vacuum you have a larger
pressure
because of the bubbling in front of you
being a little more energetic because of
the blue shift and be rather than behind
and this exerts a force against you and
that's basically why acceleration is not
quite as big this Pro this effect is
more pronounced in a gradient so when
the space time is curved so you over
here you've got squash space time over
the last squash space and then this
effect is simply what we describe as
Newtonian gravitation if you're in the
regime where you're basically a symmetry
so you have the particle which is
accelerating and the vacuum here is as
unsquatched as over there then you
effectively have a large acceleration
because the effect largely disappears
yeah that's a point and so this paper is
a very remarkable research paper because
it opens the pathway towards a Quantum
gravitational understanding of nature
which the community has been entirely
ignoring because everybody knows there
is dark matter for effect essentially
the colleagues are completely convinced
while believing in dark matter and uh
and uh where they ignore the
falsifications of Dark Matter entirely
because it's become a question of belief
in the scientific system so we've got
two theories now which will account for
the same observations one postulates
stuff we can't see
and the other one postulates a shift in
the way we understand gravity that goes
back to Weinstein and says that gravity
will change in different parts of space
so what do you think how do you think
you could distinguish between these two
things it's completely simple uh so you
have to be pragmatic you have to do your
job as a scientist properly
falsification is the key words
you test the one Theory Dark Matter
exists tested is falsified with more
than five Sigma it doesn't exist you
drop it you don't even touch it anymore
ever in Armada search group group you do
not touch dark matter anymore the and
then you look at the other hypothesis it
has to be then a modification of gravity
or not a modification it's just a
different form of gravity I do not like
the to modification because nature does
not modify it right it's just a
different law and then we work with that
loan we try to falsify that equally so
far every single prediction made in 1983
you look at the three research purposes
Milgram has published he puts on a
number of predictions what galaxy should
behave like if that formulation of
gravitation is through every one of them
has been verified to an incredible
amount even galaxies which were not
known to exist at that time
come in and try to explain why we
haven't all stopped working on dark
matter
so the the main kind of disagreement
with the the Dark Matter model that
Pablo's describing is
that there are galaxies that are are
moving faster than we think that they
should be
when you have two galaxies that merge in
particular if they're all full of dark
matter the kind of gravity of this dark
matter should slow them down
and we see galaxies moving
faster than some of our modeling
suggests that they should be
now within the Dark Matter model
and indeed also within modify gravity
I would say we don't actually have a
theory that predicts exactly how fast
all these galaxies should be moving
there's a lot of inputs into that so one
of them is indeed slowing down through
dark matter but you would also need to
really know the the cosmological history
of all of these galaxies the effect of
all of the very complicated physics of
the stars and other kind of regular
matter Within These galaxies should come
into play
so I think within the Dark Matter model
the reason we haven't just all said well
okay this is just inconsistent we're
going to stop working on it
is that it's really quite a complicated
question how fast Galaxy should be
moving and the Dark Matter model has
been so successful at explaining other
observations that I really think we
should just be working on both
well I might interject here because I
hear the statement many times that the
Dark Matter models of course the
cosmological Dark Matter models have
been successful in accounting of a large
variety of observations it is wrong
I don't know any single observation
which has actually been successfully
reproduced by by the Dark Matter models
one case
if you look at the count the number of
galaxies within our surroundings you go
out to hundreds of millions of light
years you can count the number of
galaxies per unit space you have right
and we see that the density of meta
increases out to
um about
um
1500 million light years so that's
already a large distance
um and um which means we live in a
gigantic under density this is called
the KBC void which was discovered by
Keenan bag and koi in 2012 and has been
verified by subsequent studies also
looking at the number of Galaxy clusters
we live in a region of cosmological
space which has a lower mass density a
smaller number of Galaxy clusters
smaller number of galaxies than further
out now that huge and void is completely
inconsistent with the Lambda CDM model
that lumbarcity model by the Assumption
of how does that mean the Dark Matter
yeah I don't think that's synonymous so
the uh because it assumes homogeneity
and isotropy which is reasonable but it
cannot allow such large discrepancies in
okay so Pavel you're saying that the
current data is inconsistent with
Dartmouth I I thought that modern Dark
Matter were kind of equivalent in that
they're arguing for the same but you're
saying no the data out there is
currently inconsistent with with dark
matter and is consistently modern
absolutely because well the remarkable
thing about this is you can you can test
whether this under density can account
occur in the stock meta model it cannot
Beyond it can okay can you uh Enlighten
us when we've got two a conflicting
accounts of where the dark matter is
still a viable Theory or not it's a note
in the context here about whether a
theory is successful or not or whether
there's evidence of it cosmology uh is
in a very unique uh position as a
science has also develop its own
Criterion for evidence so the goal posts
for what counts the scientific evidence
has also shifted in the 20th century at
the same time there are arguments of
course that if you are looking at very
large scales or in micro like in physics
at the you know theoretical physics
Eugene do need sort of other criteria to
access things but this is a very this is
a very questionable thing I mean uh
Lambda CDM model or the standard model
is sometimes called a concordance model
because this is the principle that was
invented it's something called
concordance is considered evidence in
cosmology no other Sciences has this and
so what it means to for something to be
proven in cosmology is if you can infer
consistent patterns across multiple data
sets that is inferred as evidence that
the theory you used to create it is
correct okay and that means you can you
can claim uh that you have really solid
evidence for dark matter but yet you
have no observational evidence for any
single parameter so Francesca have you
been Shifting the goal posts
I think what Beyond saying is basically
correct in terms of
what is considered evidence within
cosmology is to do with often
consistency within the current model but
there's a very good reason for that
which is that in cosmology are the thing
we're studying is the whole universe so
all we can do is look at the sky with
telescopes we cannot do experiments
because we only have one universe and we
didn't get to choose the starting
conditions if I'm doing an experiment in
biology
I can you know try design the exact
setup that I want in an Laboratory
cosmology and astrophysics are more like
archeology all we can do is look at
what's happened
so in that way we have had to
develop different ways of doing things
now I would say that
there have been you know some things
that are predictions in the more normal
sense
um so for example if Dark Matter exists
and Einstein's theory of general
relativity is broadly speaking correct
even at large scales then we would
expect to observe
um the bending of light around dark
matter this is called gravitational
lensing and then you know indeed we have
observed that
so there are some things where you can
kind of make predictions and see them
but with a lot of science these days and
particularly a lot of fundamental
physics there's so much input that needs
to go into every calculation you have to
make so many assumptions and everyone
has to do that we have to do it you have
to do it if you're calculating and
modify gravity you have to do that to
calculate anything that it can be quite
hard to disentangle exactly what's the
prediction and what's just consistency
within the theory I think there's no
clear-cut line between those two well in
fact that leads us to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas